volvemos en 324 y tenemos ahora aquí en
esta prevista ni él hablando quiero
explicar lo más importante hoy en
materia de economía daniela y empezamos
hablando de américa latina y el caribe
que perdieron unos 26 millones de
puestos de trabajo durante el año 2020
así es liliana buenas noches esta es la
conclusión a la que llega la
organización internacional del trabajo
en su más reciente informe este se
complementa con un estudio publicado
también hoy por una ong canadiense
llamada curso internacional que dice que
una de cada seis personas de entre 18 y
29 años ha perdido su empleo desde que
inició la pandemia está obligado a
muchos a abandonar sus estudios según la
oit la crisis organizada por el cob y
originada por el commit 19 hizo que la
tasa promedio de ocupación en la región
bajará del 57,4 por ciento en 2019 al
57,1 por ciento en 2020 es decir casi 6
puntos por debajo y representa esos 26
millones de plazas laborales menos que
usted mencionaba es indicador de
ocupación mide el porcentaje de aquellos
en edad de trabajar que efectivamente
están ocupados pero también hay que
resaltar liliana la inmensa cantidad de
informales que muchas veces no figuran
en estos registros el problema no son
únicamente los empleos perdidos la oit
destaca que también ha habido un
descenso en el número de horas
trabajadas y en el ingreso por salarios
bueno daniela y se desvanece la
posibilidad de que amazon tenga su
primer sindicato en eeuu los empleados
del centro de operaciones del gigante de
comercio electrónico en vez m en alabama
votaron recientemente para definir si se
sindicalizan o no el conteo que inició
el jueves ya está arrojando los primeros
resultados en los que él no le está
ganando al sí por más del doble de los
votos miren y gana en total fueron
emitidas un poco más de tres mil
papeletas y cualquiera de las dos
opciones gana si obtiene más de la mitad
hasta el momento cerca de 500 votaron a
favor de crear el sindicato y más de
1100 lo hicieron en contra esta firma
está dirigida por el hombre más rico del
mundo
jeff bezos y es el segundo empleador del
país sólo superada por walmart
por ahora no tiene ningún sindicato y en
el país y es conocida por su oposición a
los esfuerzos organizativos de sus
empleados así se vio a lo largo de la
campaña por ejemplo el mismo presidente
job aiden habló del tema bueno y en
bolivia inició la negociación de salario
mínimo y la cuéntenos cómo van estas
conversaciones pues estas conversaciones
se llevan a cabo cada año antes del
primero de mayo y desde que evo morales
asumió el poder inclusive ya que no está
nunca han incluido a los empresarios por
eso yo siempre han criticado que el
aumento sea consensuado sólo con los
trabajadores el salario mínimo de
bolivia equivale a 304 dólares al cambio
de hoy en 2020 no hubo aumento por la
pandemia y en 2019 el entonces
mandatario dispuso aumentar en un 3% el
salario mínimo nacional y en un 4% el
sueldo básico o el de contratación para
este año los sindicatos están pidiendo
un 5 por ciento para ambos casos
daniela y los precios mundiales de los
alimentos se dispararon durante el
último año y liliana sólo en marzo
subieron por décimo mes consecutivo y
también alcanzaron
el más alto desde junio de 2014 según la
organización de naciones unidas para la
alimentación y la agricultura el impulso
del mes vino por el lado de los aceites
vegetales las carnes y los lácteos
sin embargo liliana si se compara con
los precios de hace un año
el alza es mucho más significativa los
precios en general han subido casi un
25% como vemos en el gráfico pero el
mayor impacto en estado ha estado en los
aceites vegetales que casi se duplicaron
el azúcar y los cereales han aumentado
su valor en cerca del 30% en apenas un
año y los lácteos han subido en más del
15% el único alimento que ha bajado de
precio en pandemia dentro de las cinco
categorías que mide la fao es la carne y
cuéntanos cómo están los indicadores de
la jornada hubo un segundo recuerdo
consecutivo para el índice standard and
poor's que recordemos mide el
comportamiento de las 500 empresas más
grandes listadas en la bolsa de nueva
york en europa el índice principal de la
bolsa de parís alcanzó un techo que no
se veía hace 14 años y en américa
latina' las pérdidas fueron para la
bolsa de comercio de buenos aires que
bajó más del 1 por ciento y finalizamos
daniela con la cifra del día que nos
cuenta liliana 4 67 % esta fue la
inflación anual en méxico hasta marzo y
es la cifra más alta desde 2018 gracias
por la información de colombia ariel
adiós hoy gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en las 24 ustedes pueden continuar
con más de tras 24 puntos nos vemos más
adelante